let's go to our caller from the
four-to-three area code who's calling
today from four to three all right it
doesn't sound great Bobby but we'll do
it all right thank you very much hey
first of all just wanted to say that
whoever was calling earlier about they
don't understand why why Trump gets the
amount of support yeah look it's team
sport down here I live in rural
Tennessee and like I mean as long as you
got a Dean X to your name they're gonna
vote against you and they're gonna hate
you but it doesn't matter right right
right but overall for the Democrats for
the impeachment inquiry like I the
Democrats need to stop letting
Republicans make mistakes right the
Republicans go to make a mistake and
then Nancy Pelosi comes out and she says
hey you better not do that no like
follow Napoleon's quote never interrupt
your enemy while they're in the middle
of making a mistake right so let them
perjure themselves let them hide
evidence let them do it all and then
just nail them to the cross but the
Democrats have to grow spine and they're
gonna have to hold people inherent
contempt they're gonna have to cut their
paychecks you know I mean they're gonna
have to get nasty because it's team
sport for these guys and I mean and they
just don't care so that was it I just
wanted to give a little spiel about that
I hope you have a good day sir all right
thanks yeah I totally agree I mean
listen if what's the point of an
impeachment inquiry and request to
appear and subpoenas and the entire
thing if they ignore them and there's no
consequences it's completely pointless
and my commentary earlier this week said
literally exactly that I you know grow a
spine yes I mean I think that that's not
completely unfair language to use but
it's if we don't see the co-equal branch
of government assert its constitutional
duties and powers then they're just
going to get away with it the way
they've gotten away with it all along
other than you know some token people
Michael Cohen or Flynn or whatever else
so Bobby from Tennessee is absolutely
spot-on sorry I didn't get to everybody
who's holding we will take
more calls next week I will take a quick
break and be back with much much more
right after this